le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
définition possible de secte j'ai fait
partie de la commission parlementaire en
belgique qui s'est penché sur ce sujet
et en fait elle avait demandé à quatre
professeurs de différentes universités
francophones comme flamands de venir
expliquer quelle était la différence
entre une secte est une religion et sans
nous concerter on a tous dit la même
chose c'est impossible parce que il n'ya
pas de critères qui permettent de mettre
d'un côté les bons d'un côté les
méchants c'est le pouvoir politique qui
désigne qui est une bonne religion et
qui est une c'est le pouvoir politique a
le pouvoir de décider ce qu'ils vont
être subsidiés ou ceux qui vont être
persécutés au contraire et moi je ne
suis d'aucun de ses mouvements mais je
trouve assez dramatique qu'on perde
beaucoup de temps de fonctionnaires et
d'argent à persécuter des gens comme
l'armée du salut les adventistes du
septième jour où même les témoins de
jéhovah je pense qu'il ya des urgences
qui sont différentes et je pense que
tout ce temps et ce personnel qui a été
consacré à cela aurait mieux fait d'être
consacré véritablement à la lutte contre
des ennemis de la démocratie contre les
terroristes entre qui mène
[Musique]